these king penguins live on a small
island in the Crozet archipelago halfway
between the southern tip of Africa and
Antarctica here in the Southern Ocean
the penguin is at the top of the food
chain so scientists study populations
like this to gauge how climate change is
affecting the whole southern ocean
ecosystem to keep track of individual
Birds they use flipper bands which the
birds soon get used to wearing or so it
was assumed but a ten year study now
shows that banded birds produce fewer
chicks and have a lower survival rate
than their unbanded neighbors this casts
doubt on data collected from banded
penguins jeopardising attempts to use
this data to assess the impact of
climate change on marine ecosystems the
researchers followed the fate of a
hundred king penguins from 1998 to 2008
each penguin had a minut transponder tag
inserted under its skin using these tags
together with a system of antennas and
video cameras the researchers were able
to monitor their penguins as they move
between the island breeding site and the
sea half of the penguins also wore
conventional flipper bands these metal
bands are easy to spot at a distance
using binoculars but compared with the
transponder tags they're heavy and they
damage the flipper
the team noticed that the banded birds
arrived later for breeding and spent
more time at scene foraging for food in
the water the metal band seems to
increase drag which affects the
hydrodynamics of the penguin
this makes swimming less efficient and
more tiring so it takes longer to catch
food and this means the banded birds
chicks get less to eat over the decade
the researchers found that the banded
penguins have 39 percent fewer chicks
and a 16 percent slower survival rate if
the way we monitor penguin populations
changes how they behave there's a bias
in the data researchers may need to find
less harmful ways of identifying and
following individual animals and where
we use data collected from banded
penguins to make conclusions about
climate change we must take into account
the flip side of flipper banding